you said
cocoon that and you kind of uh
uh paint uh i think in the book i've
read a lot of your articles too on
scientific american which are brilliant
so i'm kind of mixing things up in my
head a little bit
but there's uh what does that
cocoon look like what is the
civilization that's able to harness
the power of multiple suns for example
um
look like when you imagine possible
civilizations that are
a million years more advanced than us
what do you think that actually like
looks like i think it's very different
than we can imagine
by the way i should start from the point
that even biological
life you know just without technology
getting into the game
uh could look like something we have
never seen before
take for example the nearest star which
is proxima centauri
it's four and a quarter light years away
so they will know
about the results of the 2016 elections
only next month in february 2021
it's very far away um but
if you think about it um you know this
this
star is a is a dwarf star and it's much
cooler than
it's uh twice as cold as the sun
okay and it emits mostly infrared
radiation
so if there are any creatures on
the planet close to it that is habitable
which is called proxima b
there is a planet in the habitable zone
in the zone just at the right distance
where in principle liquid water can be
on the surface
if there are any animals there they have
infrared eyes because
our eyes was designed to be sensitive
to where most of the sunlight is in the
visible range
but proxima centauri is mostly infrared
so
you're not the nearest to see each other
in the nearest star system
these animals would be quite strange
they would have
eyes that are detectors of infrared very
different from ours
moreover this planet proxima b faces the
star
always with the same side so it has a
permanent dayside
and a permanent night side and obviously
the creatures that would
evolve on the permanent day side which
is much warmer
would be quite different than those on
the permanent night side
between them there would be a permanent
sunset
strip and my daughters said that that's
the best opportunity for
high value real estate because you will
see the sunset
throughout your life right it never the
sun never sets
on this on this trip so you know these
worlds are
out of our imagination just even the
individual creatures this
the sensor suite that they're operating
with might be very different very
different so i think when we
see something like that we would be
shocked
you